[Music]
twitch is currently being used to
launder money how wow what interesting
what do you want
all right what people sending like like
uh followers or whatever or if you send
if i send like money to my favorite
twitch stream or whatever then that
becomes their you know there so they
don't so they'll take the twitch
commission it doesn't matter because the
way i can see is like let's say i have a
twitch channel right but we're all in
honest together yeah you guys have all
the drug money but you have different
accounts that you send to me and then i
put it through my
you know twitch business and into my
account if i send him if i send money to
you through twitch do you the person
that receives it you have to claim that
as income is it as gifts yeah it's the
same thing as youtube it's income yeah
yeah it's income very close
but you haven't quite washed it yet so
what they're doing is they steal credit
card information of random individuals
right then they negotiate deals with
twitch streamers who are in on it to
send them large payments and then the
streamer would refund the money that
they received to a different bank
account belonging to the hackers wow
that's smart it sounds like even more
paper trails though yeah i'll let for
like everybody i just seems very like
that's like uh that's like gift card
fraud oh cause there's the element of
threat the theft that i didn't consider
i don't know there was theft i just
thought i needed money to like
get get clean through other transfers
and make it look legitimate as like a uh
like income for somebody else yeah they
can't get tracked because of this show
is brought to you by expressvpn
it's such a good vlog
so let's say i'm
the uh i'm the i'm the fraud expert
right or like i come in you're the
twitch streamer and i break a deal with
you so i steal a credit card and i give
you
donations and then you keep it
and then what do you do after that you
send it into my one of my fake accounts
uh well i'm going to send it to a
different bank account we're funding it
to a different bank account that you're
refunding it yeah refunding infuses the
money oh you refuse it and then send it
back to a different bank account right
correct i'm refunding it though yeah
yeah well yeah like not refusing it but
yeah you're like it's kind of like if it
was a paypal transaction or whatever and
then like okay so i
i use my credit card it goes in and then
you give me a refund to another account
exactly
and because you're not using your credit
card you're using someone's that you
fraudulently obtained that's why that's
how they're washing the money but they
got caught uh another thing that that
was interesting that really triggered
the whole thing is that
um
the streamers were getting like 40 or 50
viewers a day but they were making like
eighteen hundred dollars a day wow
that's how you know that's weird yeah
and they weren't even naked
yeah yeah they were showing pits yeah
there's some weird stuff on twitch too
some good [ __ ] you ever see the guy like
sleeping and then people like just
donate money to him just sleeping all
the time i've heard about it wasn't
there a dude making seven figures well
not on twitch but to let others wake his
ass up
that sounds stressful i can't live like
that i've never even been on twitch i
don't even know what the platform is
which is crazy you're missing out bro
yeah yes but it's like got its own
categories like asmr gaming there's like
cooking top channels girls with gazongas
yeah doing asmr that that's correct
asmr [ __ ] hot girls just going up to a
mic and looking like this i gotta get a
little entertained
100 you're joking but 100 dude i saw
where a girl just had a [ __ ] feather
duster and she's sitting there putting a
feather duster on a microphone and you
hear the let's play some games look at
this that's a game let's play some games
and she has [ __ ] somebody's chinese
math homework you [ __ ] on their own
[Laughter]
horses they're coughing on a pretty gas
banana pretty compelling argument it's
called a double entendre my friends very
subtle very very subtle writing you have
to really know what this nice phallic
symbol as a writer do you appreciate
that subtlety in the very subtle my
favorite thing is when this person does
this not hating on them but then on
their tweet they'll go had the hardest
day ever
yeah
today
stressed
wake up and grind this banana banana
deflated today i don't know you guys
[ __ ] don't know how hard i work out
in these screens
how much how much money do you think
that lady pulls in oh [ __ ] ladies
you think steve you know what i'm going
to say dude go ahead you know what i'm
going to say about him wait is she is
she one of the cars is this an example
is she one of the cons no i think this
is just an example for barclays only
fans makes more money for these kind of
chicks or twitch
they might be doing dipping onto both
probably probably not double triple
quadruple dip on everything i think only
fans is more passive this is like but
they just do regular gaming too it's
just a whole mixture of this nothing has
changed since the beginning of man true
hot people and sex always [ __ ] sell
oh yeah and i always see this on food
channels i'm always looking up food [ __ ]
cooking [ __ ] right really that like some
of the people who have the worst recipes
but it's the hottest girl they get so
much more views but their [ __ ]
recipes suck it's so [ __ ] bad today
we're making grilled cheese again
with an iron today but my outfit's
different trader joe's frozen orange
chicken and it's like i don't need you
to make a [ __ ] video for this you
jackass do you comment on it do you talk
[ __ ] i masturbate too the best is the
best is when you talk to some of these
people sometimes and like yeah like i'm
really interested in making comedy
content yeah yeah different i do
different jokes
and i'm like yeah tell us one i've been
working on different bits that's a good
bit that's pretty her gazungas are crazy
she probably has a little backpack
they're way too big though they're
definitely natties they're maddie's dude
she's daddy she's quite hot she looks
like jessica rabbit oh [ __ ] she's like a
real lifestyle yeah the
no no i would say no to this woman no
thank you yeah yeah i don't think so
because i think i
i don't watch porn guys i've never
watched the best i i've never watched
porn uh what's that like huh
biggest biggest fact if a guy says that
to you just know he's watched the most
sickest [ __ ] out he just watched porn
yeah that's what he's trying to say he
jacks off to [ __ ] like animal porn
the craziest [ __ ] i've ever heard what
is her name what is her name i know i'm
gonna send this to you guys what did you
what did you type to look for that i
just typed in jacuzzi twitch stream
it's so new and it's so neat see if
she's live streaming right now i'm not
hating on her is it bose crushing it on
twitch right now i think bose is the top
black female twitch streamer that's
crazy
yeah hey
that [ __ ] [ __ ] kills it dude it's
kind of crazy what's her content would
she play very very very she does murder
mystery [ __ ] and like crime stuff but
she does it like in her own flair with
her own jokes and [ __ ] that girl could
talk to a doorknob for seven days and it
would be interesting yeah and it would
be interesting you gotta you gotta show
it they're coming up right yeah on
november 11th we're gonna do a live a
live podcast doing that anaheim house of
blues oh that's a good venue that
venue's a lot bigger than i thought so
buy those tickets please oh [ __ ] i was
like it's like way bigger than the
hollywood one like a thousand seats i'm
like oh what the [ __ ] is this
you're like oops i know i was like uh
can we bring it up 200.
like hey thanks for coming due to covet
obviously to be restricted with the
amount of uh i've already used that
excuse me that's perfect that's what i
would do as we do our [ __ ] jokes it
just echoes in the empty room
it's the one guy in the back huh thanks
to covet cover cover bro this girl got
ass too where unfortunately that's one
of my favorite things
i don't give a [ __ ] what is her [ __ ]
ass is nice i want to see wait i'm more
wrath but she's not live right now i'm
like darn oh
she's talented
changing into a cute bikini great
personality that's changing into a cute
bikini dude that's her stream how the
[ __ ] you gonna make seven figures on
that that's so dope i can i can see how
she would make some figures on that i
can see god is fair though they made
girls with shame so she's shaped like an
anime cartoon
and i hate it i hate it so much god who
finds that attractive no no not any of
us not me makes me want to throw up same
bro she looks like a [ __ ]
very interesting yeah is it like thai it
looks like no i think there's shout outs
for the dudes that are [ __ ] donating
i think they're i don't think that's
tattoos they look like margaret it was
like [ __ ] sanskrit
right damn she worldly dude
how much would you pay to like if a fan
was like paid to get you to get there
like get a shout out on your arm like
how what's what's your price dude dudes
tattoo that [ __ ] without any money yeah
but like what is your price
for me to pay them no no like if a fan
were to pay you oh you get tattooed or
to get a tattoo of with their shout out
on it or like maybe 3.70
or something but not 16 these comments
are great man somebody says you like fat
dicks right
[Laughter]
yeah people wrote that comment like this
[ __ ] right here she's gonna know he's
like she's
like she's gonna be like yeah big boy i
love fat dicks yeah but she's never
heard this one before that's a comment
that you write then you giggle and you
run away
you close your laptop
that guy is 37 years old and he [ __ ]
and that guy was me dude that guy was me
oh [ __ ]
the piranha method hey look i i get this
though she is uh quite a specimen i
think she's very smart i don't get it i
wonder how much he makes though like i'm
just curious like ballpark yo man some
of these you'll probably find that on
social blade they make what you could
probably find that on social blade oh
like her how much you like a rough
ballpark twitch estimates yeah they have
twisted twitch but they're not just
doing twitch man a lot of these girls
they're like they're killing it dude
only fans are doing all kinds of [ __ ]
services there's an nft of her dude oh
you guys want to buy it that is there's
one piece of fun look at this piece of
[ __ ]
is that it is there any more to that
is that it that's it no reserve scroll
down there's nothing more to that what's
no reserve mean there's no cap okay you
can't scroll down yeah oh yeah the other
way
no if you buy the full one then you get
to see the rest oh boy just two more
square pixels right there
two more pixels it's a whole different
it's a whole [ __ ] world but yeah it
is also being used for money laundering
which is just
another thing that you know not anymore
not that we know right now well you
don't you don't know how else it's being
used for money laundering
i assume the people who are good at it
are still doing it can't judge her man
if you guys were all hot girls we would
have done the same [ __ ] yeah dude i
appreciate you let's meet up sometime i
wish i was a hot girl dude why because i
can make something that's why i was like
god is fair dude
i was like there's a reason that god
didn't give you those powers damn it
gosh i was a hot girl i get [ __ ] by
dudes fake it bro because it's the
opposite when you're actually a hot girl
you don't [ __ ] do it yeah yeah i've
noticed that
all of our friends are [ __ ] like that
they all don't want to make money and
[ __ ] like bart could have been retired
ages ago right like david's been telling
jill he's gonna [ __ ] do her instagram
help her out you wrote her a plan too
it's a legit plan like years ago this is
before like it was like hardcore
monetized and i just saw how much like
the girls fallings were going up i was
like dude you don't have to show [ __ ]
you know just look at she had a plan
didn't do any of it dude we got a friend
she um she's got a [ __ ]
straight up
apartment overlooking times square
and she doesn't even do full nudes
but she's does only fans yeah and she
does seductive photos
makes a quarter million a month wow
[ __ ] unfair
show a little bit of areola you're good
yeah it's like seductive [ __ ] and i
heard uh um what's it called male only
fans they don't do anywhere near as good
as women of course they don't what can
guys do to make the same
without being smart drug dealing
although you got to be smart and still
be in the system yeah there's no [ __ ]
we got to build a company bro what are
you talking about
okay so like girls doing that is like
the
the taboo bad girl work right but it's
not illegal because it's still part of
this women can't capitalize off their
bodies yes correct so what is the kind
of cheat the system guys capitalizing
off of something but then it's not what
about gay only fans they monetize as
much i think they do well well they do
what gay for pay type of [ __ ] yeah gay
for people they gotta do way more
crazier [ __ ] you gotta you gotta put out
gay people get laid bro yeah you don't
have to worry yeah that's true gay dudes
be [ __ ] alive yeah because what girls
are actually doing is they're making
money off of incels yeah so how but then
what are what's the guy equivalent to
that where it's like [ __ ] uh it's
like taboo shameful [ __ ]
and it's like selling your soul a little
bit but then like you can plan poetry
but they're the brokest ones though bro
they nowadays hey steve drop what's left
you're gonna say some oh
if only everyone knew
how how big the toast could be
but if you butter the toast how can you
butter with me
[Applause]
right now
[Music]
you